so if you didn't know Hogwarts Legacy
has in fact been delayed for the
Nintendo switch all the way to November
of 2023 and I think this delay actually
confirms something that I've been
speculating about for a while and I
think I was wrong in a previous video
also there's a big reason that this
delay could actually be a good thing for
Nintendo switch owners we're going to go
over all that here today but first if
you missed this announcement it came
back on May 12th from the folks at
Avalanche they said Hogwarts Legacy
Launches on Nintendo switch on 11 14 23.
we know fans are looking forward to
playing on switch therefore creating the
best possible experience is our top
priority thank you for your patience and
then they proceed to say which versions
it is currently available on okay so why
is this a good thing because I know the
switch owners out there who have been
waiting for this this was really kind of
a gut punch the fact that you're gonna
have to wait even longer it's not easy
but reason number one I think it could
be a good thing is they do show that
they are focused on delivering the best
experience possible if you look at the
PS4 and the Xbox One versions those
actually turned out much better than a
lot of people were expecting there are
plenty of breakdown videos out there
already this show you exactly how each
version runs but overall I would say
that those on the platform still got
generally the same experience that the
rest of us did from Hogwarts Legacy
albeit with more bells and whistles if
you were on the current gen versions so
I think that's a good sign that
Avalanche was able to deliver that same
quality experience on those platforms
and you hope they'll be able to bring
the same to the Nintendo switch okay now
here's what I think I may have gotten
wrong so back when they first announced
the switch version which if you remember
was not planned from the beginning that
actually came after the initial
announcement of the game and they didn't
even make a really big deal about it was
almost kind of like it was a side note
and so my speculation for a while is
that this was going to be a cloud-based
version of Hogwarts Legacy and not an
actual physical copy of the game running
natively on the Nintendo switch yeah
this is actually a thing if you didn't
know about this there's a list of about
20 or so games according to Nintendo
life here that are available on the
switch as a cloud version the idea here
is that instead of the game running
natively on the hardware it's actually
being streamed from a server somewhere
else so this means no physical copies
for one but then you you don't even have
to download and save it to your switch
it just streams from the server now why
would they do something like this you
may ask well there are some advantages
of this first of all you don't have to
worry about having an underpowered
system because you're actually streaming
from something that is potentially even
more powerful probably a really powerful
PC so you could get great frame rates
really nice Graphics all the nice
effects all while playing on a Nintendo
switch the downside of course is that
this is totally reliant on your internet
connection so if you have a really good
connection and if you're plugged in
hardwired you're probably going to have
a pretty good experience if you're on
spotty Wi-Fi though then it's not going
to be so great also the switch is a
portable system by Nature so removing
that feature is really unfortunate for a
lot of people however I suppose it is a
nice compromise on some of these games
that may not have been made available
otherwise so because Hogwarts Legacy is
such a vast open world game and looks
pretty nice on the current Engine
Systems I've been of the opinion for a
while that they would just not be able
to get this running natively on the
switch and that it would instead be a
cloud version of the game streaming from
a server somewhere else on a more
powerful system but I think this and
announcement pretty much confirms that
that is not the case now again we can't
say 100 but I find it really hard to
believe that they would delay a game
this long if it was only a cloud version
what this delay says to me instead is
that they're taking the proper time and
really focusing to make sure that the
switch is also a quality experience like
we've seen on PS4 and Xbox One so if you
had seen my previous video on that and
you were concerned with maybe this is
going to be a cloud version I think you
could feel pretty confident now that
that is not going to be the case now
there's also one other really cool thing
that I think may be happening when the
switch version finally releases
hopefully in November hopefully they're
able to stick to that but before we talk
about that I think we have to look at
where Hogwarts Legacy is at right now
from a marketing perspective from a
community perspective because I will say
even though I have personally been done
with the game for months now the folks
over at Avalanche and WB have really
done a nice job of keeping the
conversation around this game going
they've been doing the Hogwarts Legacy
live streams we've seen consistent
tweets from them I've still seen
commercials and advertisements for the
game it's obviously sold incredibly well
and anytime they've been asked about DLC
the answer has pretty much been we were
focused on getting the PS4 and the Xbox
One versions out now that those versions
are out though does that conversation
shift in any way I mean you would
presume that they're gonna say okay now
we're focused on the switch version and
I think that's probably the case I do
still remain very confident that
Hogwarts Legacy DLC will happen it's
just a matter of when we don't know how
much work if any has been done on it so
far I think we do know from studying the
industry and from seeing what happens
with other games there's going to be a
lot of stuff that was cut a lot of
things that didn't make it into the
final game and you would hope that some
of these ideas that they really wanted
to get in maybe they're saving it
setting it aside for a sequel or setting
it aside for a potential DLC now
honestly I would absolutely love to see
a November DLC right alongside the
launch of the switch that would just
really inject some new hype and
excitement into the community but
something tells me that we're not gonna
get DLC until 2024. I hope I'm wrong on
that but we'll just have to wait and see
now the one other really cool thing that
I think could be happening when the
switch version launches is I do think we
could see the release of more new
Cosmetics through the twitch drops they
did this when the game released on
current gen they did this when the game
released on last gen and I think it
would be really cool if they did it yet
again when it releases on Nintendo
switch because as of June 2nd the
current twitch drops that they were
doing are done so the professor Ronin
gear that's finished the Merlin cloak
that everyone wanted so bad that's
finished at least for now so I think it
would be great to see those come back
don't forget we also have quidditch
Champions we also have Harry Potter
magic awakened quit as Champions we
still have no idea when that one is
going to release magic awaken they're
saying this summer here in the US and
the UK fingers crossed it's actually
gonna happen I really hope so I have
never played it and I'm really looking
forward to it and it just has me feeling
so nostalgic about all the Harry Potter
video games in fact I recently went on
my own little Quest here in the real
world to buy every single Harry Potter
game I had so much fun making this video
guys you should absolutely check that
one out next it's here on the right side
of your screen as always guys thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon